hey here is a story that I don't know if
you'll find this surprising I didn't
find it particularly surprising a new
book out explains that when Donald Trump
would see staffers of color at the White
House meaning non-white people he would
assume that they were waiters even
though they were not there's a really
good Rolling Stone article about this
which I encourage you to check out which
we will link to Trump saw staffers of
color at the White House and assumed
they were waiters when Democratic
leaders brought a racially diverse group
of staffers to a meeting the former
president assumed that they were there
to serve food oh my God like is it's
absurd but is it really that surprising
the article recounts an event in January
of 2017 when Trump had a reception with
top Congressional leaders there were
hors d'oeuvres and there were a bunch of
democratic staffers and apparently Trump
turned to them and asked them to bring
over some of the appetizers why don't
you get the food Trump told staffers for
Chuck Schumer
God it's making me cringe to even read
this Trump told staffers for Schumer
Pelosi and others
go and get the food
this is according to New York Times
Reporter Maggie haberman's new book
confidence man
then white house chief of staff rince
priebus rushed to correct Trump's remark
telling the then president that those
were top Congressional aides not White
House wait staff
Rolling Stone writes Trump's remark as
just one example of Trump's casual
racism detailed in the pages of
confidence man later in the same meeting
Trump told Schumer and Pelosi that
ballots cast by illegals were the only
reason he lost in 2016's popular vote to
Hillary
after an awkward silence Pelosi
interjected I don't believe so Mr
President oh my God
this is just wild
the book describes Trump's relationship
with Cara young a model he dated for
many years who had a black mother and a
white father after meeting Young's
parents Trump joked she got her beauty
from her mother and her intelligence
from her dad the white side Trump
laughed at his own joke young didn't and
according to the book voiced her
displeasure this is all just completely
nuts it's all completely nuts but also
completely unsurprising
um think back remember this incident
during Trump's 2016 campaign we had a
case where we had an African-American
guy who is a fan of mine great fan great
guy in fact I want to find out what's
going on with him you know what I'll
look at my African-American over here
look at him are you the greatest do you
know what I'm talking about okay
it's funny it's funny but it's also
absolutely horrifying and uh this
shouldn't really shock us remember that
Donald Trump paid for an ad in the
newspaper calling for the death of
innocent black people who had been
falsely accused of a crime it's called
the Central Park five and so I'm filing
the revelations in Maggie haberman's
book under things that we already
thought were probably true and now we
have definitive confirmation just
completely unbelievable